well thank you for talking about this
this was quite
the unexpected thrill ride i
uh i thought it was a lot of fun thank
you so much i'm glad you enjoyed it
yeah it was it was fun i didn't know
what to expect
it just kept surprising me which is nice
because that's hard to do
so congratulations on that well thank
you that was our goal we just wanted to
make something that
would be an escape for people and it was
entertaining and just fun
because we had so much fun making it
yeah and it seems like there's so many
things that could have gone
wrong just from doing like this kind of
project and trying to pull something off
in a pandemic i mean it just seems like
there are so many things that could have
not worked out
and it did it's true and at every turn
we all sort of looked at each other and
went
can we actually do this is this this is
this shouldn't work and yet it does
somehow you know there's something
should be getting in the way but no
every obstacle at every turn
either luke and nick or our producers or
our
incredible director photography kevin or
one of us would come up with an idea
that would solve any problem that got in
our way and you know i think
for us it we were also starved for not
only social interaction but some sort of
creative productivity at that point that
we were willing to just dive in and go
all right let's do this experiment let's
just see what we can accomplish
and lo and behold we have untitled
horror movie
and i love that this is so not the kind
of character that at least we've seen
you do recently
so i mean was she very defined on the
page as a character did you get to have
a hand in developing
who she is and how she would be i mean a
little bit
you know i helped to kind of further the
idea because
obviously it was a very collaborative
process throughout but uh
i was excited to see what what luke and
nick would come up with because i've
been friends with both you know luke
baines obviously from shadowhunters and
and nick simon i've known for years and
years and it's one of those things that
i was curious to see what they would
write with
you know for me to do and uh i was
thrilled again that's the joy when you
when a friend
writes the script they know what you
haven't gotten the chance to do and
you know they knew i hadn't gotten to do
comedy in a really long time and that i
had never really played a character like
this at least not for
for a good long while and uh it was so
fun to get to dive into sweet chrissy
who was just
the most over committed and
under-informed individual
um but it was so much fun i love doing
comedy it's something that i
you know rarely get a chance to do
anymore and it's uh it was great to sort
of stretch those
muscles a little bit that have not been
used for a while
was this something too where you could
add or change things kind of on the fly
because
you were doing it this way i mean did
that change
how you got to shoot it as well
absolutely so
through the magic of earpieces and
headphones
we were all able to be completely
isolated so we were on zoomed together
for the group scenes and for for all of
that but
all of our audio and video was
completely isolated as it was recorded
which allowed them all of the freedom
and editing to basically have
six cameras rolling and six separate
microphones at all times
and then you know if we were to ad lib
or
throw something in there or somebody
takes us on a tangent we can all go with
it and they have it all
captured so it gave us all of the
freedom in the world to
play and to find what the movie was
actually going to be
both tonally and in actuality you know
branching out from the script
as we were shooting since you're
basically doing
everything for yourself on this did you
find yourself enjoying like
one department more than the other since
you were sort of like the lead of each
department for yourself
yeah you know it was it was
simultaneously very exciting and very
terrifying i think all of us
wanted to not be the one to ruin the
film as it were
um you know i have such massive respect
for
crews and for their their knowledge base
and their skill set that they
you know have obviously trained and
studied and done all of these things
that i have not done i i've
had the luxury of working with some
incredible crews that have taught me a
lot over the years
and answered all of my many questions as
someone who wants to direct in the
future
um but there's a big difference between
seeing something and understanding it
versus practically doing it yourself
um but you know thank thanks to our
director of photography kevin duggan who
so
ever so patiently with the patients of
the saints taught all of us
everything we know about every
department i i've always thought that um
sort of what kevin does being a director
of photography and lighting it's always
been magic to me you know there's
there's
a way that directors of photography
paint with light and can do so much
with you know what seemingly to the
human eye
is is kind of amorphous in a way
um but through a few little bits of
rudimentary knowledge i've gotten to
play in that a little bit more even
with self tapes and interviews and
things that i've done after
i've had a lot of fun playing and seeing
what i can come up with
after the fact i love the use of shadow
in this too
because it does actually play like its
own character in
in the movie absolutely and some of that
was purposeful and some of it was we'd
be setting up a shot and kevin would go
wait what was that what made that shadow
you can use that
and that was the fun of the whole
process is that it was all a grand
experiment that we were all just open to
going all right well we're going to give
this our best shot
and see what happens do you leave a
project like this going
okay you know now i feel more secure
that i could direct if the right thing
came along
or do you go like oh my god i realize
there's so many more things i
i don't know about yet uh a bit of both
you know i think every every bit of
knowledge helps to fuel that and i know
for me
i have shattered a few directors and
i've done a little bit of studying here
and there as far as that goes and
and it only fueled my fire even more you
know i don't think i'll ever stop
telling stories in front of the camera
and creating characters but
as a director behind the camera there's
so many more tools at your disposal that
you can use to tell the story
and and to say things in interesting
ways and it only fueled my fire more to
to learn about those things
that being said i know that there is so
much yet but i still don't know
but um i learn more by doing so it makes
me more excited to
dive in what was it like to shoot this
during a pandemic i mean we were in sort
of this weird period for a while when
production shut down where people were
like oh we'll be back in production in a
couple of weeks and then there was
the period where it was like okay maybe
we'll never get back to production and
it sort of had to
find its way so what was it like to do
something like this and then also figure
out how to
still build chemistry when you're not
able to actually be in the same room
yeah that that was definitely a
consideration i think
retrospectively it was very cathartic in
a way
in that even though we don't mention the
pandemic at all
in the story you have six characters
that are dealing with this period of
uncertainty and an unknown future and
not knowing
what their lives are going to consist of
and they all deal with it in very
different ways
and thinking back on it all of us were
in the same place
we were all at home not knowing what the
world was going to look like in
you know six hours let alone six weeks
and uh
it it was definitely i think a
way of therapeutically working through
this place that all of us were in
mentally and emotionally as well as
telling a story that will hopefully help
other people do the same
but as far as the chemistry goes as you
know you know so much of the film relies
on that banter and that kind of
chemistry
i was lucky in the fact that i knew tim
and claire and luke
from beforehand um and so i i
you know had a bit of a relationship
there already but
that was a big question for all of us
because if you don't have that
spark that a whole movie isn't gonna
work and somehow from the first table
rate on zoom
something just clicked and all of us
looked at each other
virtually and went oh actually there's
something here
and we're all on the same wavelength
even though some of us have never even
met and still to this day we all have
not physically been in the same room
together
so hopefully that'll happen soon and
we'll be able to
to either you know go on a group
vacation or i don't know maybe shoot a
sequel in person
shadowhunters was a show that had a very
loyal and very devoted fan base
has that fever died down at all or do
you still get comments from fans about
it
it's so interesting because i
i never expected this when i first
started the show you know i was so
excited and
being a fan of why as a kid as well i i
know the responsibility of taking on a
story like this
and taking on a character like clary
that people are so attached to in a
world that people
relate to so much and love um
but the shadow fan is so special you
know we
love to call them the shadow fam because
from our castle crew to our creatives to
the fandom
it's all one big family we really all
have the same passion for the story and
that has not ceased and i truly don't
think it ever will and that's
all a credit to the fandom in that they
have taken this
community far beyond us and the show and
our characters and created this
beautiful space
where people can feel accepted and
people can just truly be themselves and
find
kindred spirits from all over the world
and and it's just
in a space like social media that can
have so many different
um facets that run the gamut to
to have a space that is so loving and
positive it's just a gift to be a part
of
but seeing through the pandemic so many
new people discovered shadowhunters as
well
and went on the journey anew and seeing
those comments online and meeting people
at virtual comic cons and doing all of
that
it's been almost a resurgence of you
know
fresh enthusiasm into the world that
we're all just so excited to see
you also were so great on arrow because
you had that really
tough job of joining the show and
still finding a way to have that fan
base
embrace you and and you did that i mean
i i think you fit in with that show
really well and in a way that is really
challenging
and you know i personally was very
bummed to hear
that the spin-off wasn't moving forward
how hard was it to
get that news and know that you wouldn't
have closure for mia as a character in
the way that you did get
that somewhat with clary yeah i mean
joining the arrowverse in and of itself
was such a pleasure i mean coming off of
shadowhunters i was so bummed
thinking that i wouldn't my next job
probably wouldn't be
as uh active or as stunt heavy and i
wouldn't have a chance to use those
fighting skills at work every day or or
to be immersed in a fandom in a world
like shadowhunters and then arrow
happened and i was so thrilled to be
able to dive in headfirst
granted i didn't know until after i was
cast that i would be playing oliver and
felicity's daughter
which is once again a whole level of
responsibility that i
i was not expecting but was very excited
for and and
ready for the challenge of diving in and
going how do i take these two characters
and this relationship that is so beloved
by the fandom
and do justice by it and and create a
character that's an amalgamation
of these two really specific wonderfully
developed humans
um and and i was just so grateful that
stephen and emily and everyone on the
show and in the in the whole arrowverse
welcomed me in with open arms and and
just made me feel so at home
and including the fandom as well you
know i i was a bit nervous to see
how how they would accept mia and what
they would think
because the take that that we took with
her was
was very distinct and there was really
you either
you were getting either love it or not
and most people really took to mia and i
was so grateful for that um
but yeah i mean look the one thing
you're always sure of
in the entertainment industry is that
eventually a job will
come to a close but the great thing
about
the arrowverse and the great thing about
mia is that
you know the the arrowverse still exists
and mia lives on and comic cons and as
people re-watch the show
and and all of these things that you
know continue to happen and
as much as i would have loved to
continue her story i i was just so
grateful to be a part of it
when you have an experience like that do
they tell you why the show doesn't get
picked up do they ever give you a reason
for their decision or do the actors not
get that
information unfortunately at least as in
my experience
actors are usually the last to know
anything and have any
information when it comes to these
things so i
i don't know why i i don't even have the
the authority to speak on the matter
really other than
i i wish it had gone forward and you
know i
i was excited to see what the future
held but you know
that's how the cookie crumbles are you
still
game to return to the character in some
capacity especially
if like legends find themselves in 2040
i mean look the arrow versus what it is
and i have no idea what their future
plans are
but i would jump at the chance to go
back and play again again
there's so many wonderful people over at
wp and cw in the whole berlanti world i
i loved working there and you know if
they ever need me back i'm happy to go
shoot arrows again
acting didn't start out as a planned
career for you but you went
from stage to film and tv you've been
you know working
pretty consistently when you realized
that this was what you actually wanted
to do
what did you envision for yourself
wouldn't being a successful actor look
like in the beginning
it's funny you ask that because that's
changed over the years and that's
something that i love most about my
career is it's constantly evolving and
constantly changing
um at first i i would say
that it's very different than it is now
even i i wanted to be an economist
before i was an actor i wanted to you
know
work in financial planning or
developmental economics or something of
that nature and that's actually what i
went to school for
and you know growing up in kansas city
they have a huge theater community there
as well
and my plan was to work in a financial
institution
and then that closes at five so i can
make it to the theater by eight o'clock
for curtin and it works out perfectly
and that's
that was what i thought my life would be
and i thought how great i can you know
do both things that i love
then i ended up booking a broadway show
and moved to new york and then i went oh
my gosh this is what i'm gonna do for
the rest of my life i'm gonna live in
new york and work in a broadway theater
and this will be fantastic
then i booked a job in la and ten years
later i'm still here
going back and forth doing all these
things so at this point
i'm just open to whatever the future
holds and as long as i get to keep
working in different mediums i'd love to
go back to theater i'd love to do more
film i'd love to do another tv show i i
want to direct
soon i'm developing projects i'm doing
music i'm
kind of putting my hand in everything
because i i think diversity
in creative exploits are what fuels my
soul the most and keeps me growing and
keeps me challenged and that's
that's what i would like to do i think
just um
continuing forward motion is my idea of
success
when you found out that you would be
filming a scene for this where you
essentially have to strangle yourself
what what what goes through your head
what's that like to shoot what's it like
to watch that later
uh watching it's a bit funny i'm i'm a
bit funny about watching myself but
you know that's just part of part of the
job i guess um
i did turn to luke and go is this
because clary killed jonathan in
shadowhunters is this why
this is happening um but you know he
gives the sly luke bain smirk so you
never really know why
but uh but no it was a lot of fun i knew
again
given that luke and i are such good
friends
he knows i have stunt mats at my house
and so he knows that if anyone's
equipped during a pandemic to safely do
stunts
it's me so hence the fact that i end up
doing a lot of the stunts in the film
um but it again it's a lot of fun to get
to
try your hand literally at something new
and
being a huge fan of thrillers and horror
and all of those things growing up
it's fun to get to experiment with what
do i have in my house that can make this
as creepy as possible and how can i
manipulate the few tools that i have
to create an environment um that would
be a real set
how hard is it to figure out those
emotional levels or what you want to do
physically when you don't
have somebody walking you through all
that with you yeah well we were really
lucky i mean nick is such a fantastic
director and is so collaborative
and really honest and that's all you can
ask for from a director is someone who
can kind of guide you
having the scope of the whole film to
sort of help you find those levels and
and
find where it fits in the greater realm
of the story
um but also we were lucky enough to be
able to call on
some folks that we'd worked with before
from shadowhunters in
you know the all the different
departments including stunts
we uh we reached out to a few of our our
stunt
performers and coordinators and friends
from that show who then sent us a video
of hey if we were to do these things in
our house this is how to safely do it
but also make it
look realistic enough on camera and how
to shoot it and where to position the
camera and how to position yourself with
the camera which are normally
all things the stunt coordinator would
tell you and have planned out with the
director
and the camera operators on the day um
but in this case we had
to do it all ourselves so we were really
lucky to have those resources and
and you know given the pandemic a lot of
people had the time
to take a few minutes to to teach us and
we're happy to help given that we all
needed a bit of creativity in our lives
at that point
well i was very impressed with
everything that you pulled off in this
because it it just seemed like there
were endless
possible challenges along the way with
something like this
absolutely and there were but that was
the joy of it is that you know
as creatives and as artists we we always
tend to be overcoming obstacles in one
way or another and this was just
another opportunity to do that so thank
you i'm really glad you enjoyed it
yeah it was very creative so thanks a
lot thank you